okay welcome everybody we just hit this
button here okay good so okay in the
last few lectures we've been looking at
the geometry of solutions of linear
rotis right and we're just starting to
think about nonlinear ordinary
differential equations which are much
more like what we're actually going to
come in contact with on a daily kind of
research basis and so what I'm going to
do today is just briefly review kind of
all of the canonical types of solutions
you can get for a linear system and then
we're gonna dive into nonlinear systems
that come from potential potential
energy equations okay so we're gonna get
into some physics today's some nonlinear
ode E's and we're going to see how this
geometric view of ordinary differential
equations make sense with physical
systems I posted the third homework
today it is due next Friday and the week
after homework three is due there will
be a midterm exam so the midterm will
come out on Wednesday and I think it'll
be due on Friday which is Halloween but
it'll be due way before everyone should
start drinking hopefully there could be
some overlap and I think that there's no
homework due on the Halloween week
there's a homework to you the following
week okay so I'm just gonna do a quick
overview overview of two by two linear
systems x equals ax so let's just I'm
just going to go down the list and we're
just going to draw a picture so we have
them kind of in the back of our mind
okay so if I if my a matrix is something
like one zero zero two
what does that solution look like
it's unstable how do you know it's
unstable positive eigenvalues what are
the eigenvalues 1 and 2 you can always
read them off for a diagonal or an upper
or lower triangular matrix okay so the
eigenvalues are 1 & 2 what are the
eigenvectors this is a diagonal matrix
so the eigenvectors are the unit
x-direction and the unit y-direction
okay so it's a little more unstable in
the y-direction but it's still pretty
unstable in the x-direction and so my
solutions look like that every single
solution you can think of except for
ones that stay exactly at the at the
origin will explode away from the origin
okay this is called an unstable source
okay let's try another one a equals one
minus one what's that
stability wise okay it's called a stable
is it it's called a saddle is it stable
or unstable not both its unstable it has
one stable direction but the other
unstable direction will pretty much
always take me away from the fixed point
again what are the eigenvectors what's
the unstable eigenvector the x-axis
what's the stable eigenvector the y-axis
right the one corresponding to this
eigenvalue so the y-axis is stable the
x-axis is unstable and pretty much all
of my solutions still move away to
infinity but they move away to infinity
on the x axis on this this manifold okay
this is called a Sabbath and it's
definitely unstable okay what if I have
a equals 0 1 minus 1 0 what about that
one sorry you say stable or unstable
uncie well why do you think it's
unstable what are the eigenvalues for
this one
okay so this one has eigenvalues plus or
minus I and so it's going to be a Silla
turret we're gonna get pure sines and
cosines let's not think about the
eigenvectors for now but basically the
whole plane both the X and the y
directions are stable and so I get these
closed orbits where if I start with a
given radius I keep that radius forever
okay
this is kind of stable we call it stable
but it's really neutrally stable so
solutions neither grow nor decay they
just kind of stay at the same size if I
added a little bit of non-linearity to
this equation then this could go either
way it could become stable or it could
become unstable okay let's say I do one
final one I have a equals minus 1 1
minus 1 0 minus 1 what about this one
this is the last one we did in class yes
on Wednesday okay well these eigenvalues
aren't too bad it's lambda equals minus
1 plus or minus I and so is this stable
or unstable
I don't you think it's stable how many
think it's unstable how many think it's
a neutrally stable okay so this is
stable the way we know is because it has
real part if the real part of lambda is
negative then it's stable if the real
part of all of my eigen values are
negative then my system stable okay
because my solution is going to look
like e to the lambda t it's gonna look
like a bunch of e to the lambda T's and
that's going to be e to the minus 1 plus
or minus I minus 1 plus or minus I T and
remember Exponential's if I multiply two
Exponential's the exponential sums so
this is e to the minus T
times e to the plus or minus I T okay
this is just sines and cosines and this
is a pure decay okay so I have a I have
a magnitude of my solution decaying and
the solutions oscillating while it
decays so remember the solution to this
looked like you know I have this
exponentially decaying envelope and my
solution is oscillating as it decays so
the phase portrait here is x1 x2 kind of
spirals into the origin forever okay so
it's stable and this is called a stable
spiral because it's spiraling in how
would I make this unstable yeah I can
make this real part positive one by
changing these off-diagonal sorry these
diagonal elements two plus one and then
this would be an unstable spiral and it
would blow up and oscillate as it does
it okay that's pretty much it
the other of course you know for this
unstable source I could also have a
stable source if I just made my
eigenvalues negative but these are the
basic building blocks for all linear
systems okay in higher dimensions you
still have these basic prototypes you
have things that are purely stable or
unstable you have things that are a mix
of stable directions and unstable
directions still called saddles you have
things that are still neutrally stable
all purely imaginary complex pairs and
then you have combinations of you know
damped or undamped oscillating complex
pairs there's one last type of system
that I haven't told you about and that's
where I have I gain values that are
really really close to each other okay
I'll just write it out over here it's
where I have I gain values that are
really close to each other like minus
0.01 0 minus 0.01 1 but I have I gain
vectors that are
very very close to parallel okay so if I
have eigenvectors that are super close
to parallel and eigenvalues that are
really close to equal I get interesting
phenomenon so this is still a stable
system but it has really interesting
transient dynamics so this is a homework
problem on homework three I want you to
play around with this and we'll talk
about it more probably on Monday but we
haven't talked about this system yet
it's a little interesting okay any
questions about these before we go on to
looking at like physics ya know so the
diagonal minus one terms are the damping
terms so if you compute the eigenvalues
of this you'll find that the the
negative part comes from these diagonal
negative ones and the oscillatory part
comes from the off diagonal like equal
and opposite plus and minus one terms so
when we dealt with the spring-mass
system we had a slightly different form
of the equations but we also got purely
complex eigenvalues so what I would
recommend doing is take that spring-mass
system and add a damping term and see
how it changes the a matrix and you'll
really see like which terms contribute
to damping and which terms contribute to
pure oscillation but the the oscillatory
term really corresponds to the position
and the velocity being out of phase with
each other okay okay good so this is
usually I'm used to teaching applied
math classes and I always promise my
students that I will never have any
physics they don't have to know any
physics at all but fortunately I assume
that most of you know a lot of physics
possibly more physics than I know so how
many of you have seen oiler lagrangians
or hamiltonian equations sometime in the
past we have not ever seen it okay it's
fine we're only going to kind of use
them as examples of equations but before
jumping into LaGrant
jeans and Hamiltonians I want us to
think about just a particle in a
potential well my old professor used to
love potential fields and he would
always take us through journeys of pop
fields which is a lot of fun okay and
we're going to use this as an example of
linearizing nonlinear ODU's okay good so
when I say a particle in a potential
well I it really is pretty simple what
I'm talking about so I literally mean I
have some potential v capital V of X of
some variable X maybe there's some
potential shape some potential function
of X and you can literally think of this
as like if I drop a ball bearing on this
surface what is the ball bearing do all
right if I drop it here it just
oscillate back and forth until I add
damping and then it oscillates and dies
if I drop it here it'll move let's say
it's a bead so it's constrained to stay
on this path then it'll move very
quickly up to the same height over here
and then it'll move back and then I'll
keep going and going and going until I
add damping in which case that'll get
trapped in one of these wells what if I
put it directly on the top of this hump
here it'll stay there unless you breathe
on it okay so really simple I mean I
literally mean there's a bead on a wire
and that wire has a shape V of X okay so
consider potential V of X and imagine
sliding a bead
on this surface so this might seem a
little cutesy like a toy problem but
this is really the first step in a huge
range of like all of classical mechanics
okay so almost any problem in classical
mechanics a pendulum a double pendulum
and automobile the planetary motion you
start with the potential field later
we'll add the kinetic energy and we'll
get the equations of motion okay so this
is going to be an extremely general
mathematical construct but for now let's
just think of a bead on a you know on a
wire okay so how many of you remember
what the force is for particle in a
potential field the F equals MA force
these are conservative forces because I
haven't added any friction sorry
well so in so in general the force is F
equals minus partial V partial X okay so
I have like more force when I have a
bigger slope less force when I have a
smaller slope okay so for example at
this hump here and at these troughs here
I have zero slope with respect to X and
I have no force pushing me in the X
direction okay my B doesn't move if you
want to think about a the gravitational
potential is like 1 over X and so the
partial of that with respect to X is 1
over x squared which is our force that
we're used to right that's the
gravitational force 1 over x squared
okay so this is you know from physics
and so what we end up getting is
essentially X double dot equals minus
partial V partial X so I'm assuming that
my mass is equal to 1 okay I have a unit
mass feed so this is nice I have a
differential equation this looks a lot
like differential equations that we are
pretty comfortable with solving now
right so we have a second-order system
we can we can write it as 2 first order
coupled systems and then we can you know
find the fixed points find the
linearization and solve the system ok we
know how to basically solve this so
we're going to do two examples of this
potential well problem today I can't
help it I'm gonna write down the
Lagrangian I really really really like
the Lagrangian this is probably the most
important so physicists have been
talking about a grand unified theory of
physics for all of my life and they're
massively overlooking the Euler Lagrange
equations this is the closest thing we
have to a grand unified theory it covers
special relativity general relativity
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics all of them in one equation ok
simultaneously if you write the
coordinates correctly
okay so let's write the Lagrangian
Lagrange's awesome so they had a library
at Caltech a math library and it was a
pretty big library on the seventh floor
of the big tall building on campus and
LeGrande to full bookcases with like
seven shelves just for his combined
volumes of math and physics he's one of
the most prolific mathematicians and
physicists to ever live and he really
got a tremendous amount of stuff right
that we're still digging through his
works finding new inspiration today
which is amazing
okay so kinetic energy is what's the
kinetic energy of a particle with
position X and velocity X dots yeah
one-half X dot squared I'm just going to
make all of my mass is equal to one I
get to do that because this is a math
class so my potential energy is V of X
and the Lagrangian is going to be the so
L of X and X dots is equal to my kinetic
energy usually just a function of X dot
not always sometimes it can depend on X
that's weird but it happens - my
potential energy which is usually just a
function of X the position ok for those
of you who can't see it it's on the side
of the screen - ok and so we can write
down the Euler Lagrange equations
as the time derivative DDT of partial L
partial X dots minus partial L partial x
equals zero for an unforced system if I
have external forcing then there would
be some generalized force or torque on
this right-hand side okay I mean so I'm
not deriving this I'm just showing you
what it is this these are the Euler
Lagrange equations if I write my
Lagrangian as kinetic minus potential
energy this satis this is the equation
you get when you write down the
principle of least action what this
means is that this particle on the on
the on this wire is going to try to find
the most efficient path that minimizes
the transfer of Pinet potential to
kinetic energy and vice versa so the
principle of least action right that's
why light changes direction when it goes
through different media like if you have
light going from air into water it turns
it's because of the principle of least
action falls rolling down a hill the
trajectory they take is because of the
principle of least action quantum
mechanics and relativity also satisfy
the principle of least action this is
just the Oh de form of the principle of
least action and you have to take my
word for it you know this isn't a
physics class I'm just writing it down
okay so what you can do is you can
actually plug in this kinetic energy and
this potential energy and you'll find
that partial L partial X dot is the same
as partial T partial X dot which is just
X dot and DDT of that adds another dot
so I have X double dot equals partial L
partial X but the only part of my
Lagrangian that depends on X is my
potential so this equals minus partial V
partial X okay so this is just another
way of getting this equation from the
Euler Lagrange equations
okay what's nice about this you know you
could derive this this expression using
Newton's second law F equals MA in a
Cartesian coordinate system but the
Euler Lagrange equations work in generic
coordinate systems so they work in the
pendulum using angular coordinates and I
don't have to do any nasty cosine and
sine transforms to polar coordinates it
just it just works if I can write down
my kinetic energy and my potential
energy in that coordinate system I can
get equations of motion really really
nice
okay good that's probably enough physics
any questions about these equations
before I go on any at all we're gonna
start using them yeah okay let's do an
example this is one of my two favorite
vector fields I have favorite vector
fields this is my second favorite vector
field
okay so X double dot equals minus X plus
x squared and this corresponds to a
potential energy of how would I figure
out what the potential energy is for
this for this oh de
yeah I would take minus the integral
because I know that this is equal to
minus partial V partial X so I'm just
gonna integrate it and take the negative
sign and I get something like x squared
over 2 minus X cubed over 3 good and I
can plot that potential curve and it
looks something like this so I'm going
to use capital V with these little bars
on top to denote the potential energy
and I'm going to use a little script v
to denote the velocity because this
thing has a velocity okay
that's what the potential energy looks
like that gives me this Oh de ok so
physically we should know exactly what's
gonna happen for every case I can think
of right I'm dropping a bead on this we
can all picture in our minds we all have
integrators in our minds that we learned
so we learned how to integrate this
system physically in our minds and we
know exactly what the beads gonna do ok
so let's say I have the bead right near
this top of the potential energy hump
and I kick it a little bit to the right
what's gonna happen when you go down
forever if I kick it a little to the
left it's going to oscillate and then
come right back and then oscillate and
then come right back unless I have
friction in which case it's going to get
trapped in as well ok now what's
interesting is we can also think about
not just starting this at initial
positions but also giving them some
initial velocities so let's say even if
I start below this hump here but I push
it to the right I give it a kick to the
right it might still make it over the
hump and go to positive infinity so
physically we know exactly what the
system is going to do that's why I like
these because we know exactly what the
system is going to do and so the OD e
actually makes physical sense when you
write it down ok so how do we solve Oh
des like this what's the first step
so I would probably try to linearize it
but I would start by writing this in a
in a suspended a data variable for
velocity right to make this a
first-order system so I have X dot
equals some little velocity and my
velocity dot is minus X plus x squared
it's fine so what are my fixed points
what are my fixed points where this is
equal to zero okay so X is equal to zero
and one what about V zero and again that
makes sense right that corresponds to X
being at zero or X being at one with
zero velocity those are my two fixed
points where the bead stays still okay
and I can write that as 0 0 the vector
and 1 0 the vector okay those are my
fixed points now what do I do what's the
next step I have fixed points I have a
system of two coupled first order
nonlinear differential equations i
linearize this nonlinear system about
each of these fixed points and I look at
what those eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of that linearization are okay so this
function f so D F D X and V is equal to
partial of this with respect to X is 0
partial with respect to V is 1 partial
of this with respect to X is minus 1
plus 2x partial of this with respect to
V is 0 ok so fixed point 1 is 0 0 that's
this point right here so DF DX at 0 0 so
I plug in 0 for X and V in this
expression what do I get
perfect okay this is one of the
canonical cases we wrote down earlier
right this has purely imaginary
eigenvalues it's a center so my
solutions just oscillate at the same
radius forever okay so this is a center
and it looks like like that okay so for
fixed point two again I take my
linearization df/dx and now I plug in
the vector 1 0 for X and V what do I get
now so I plug in 1 for X here 0 1 1 0
okay and I'm pretty sure that this gives
me I get values that are both positive 1
that's not good so it's very unstable
and ok
sorry I think this gives me eigenvalues
that are plus and minus one all right so
this is lambda equals plus and minus one
which makes this an unstable saddle okay
so that means I have a stable direction
and an unstable direction if I wanted to
know what those directions were I would
have to compute the eigenvectors okay
okay good any questions so far
we have a particle on this potential
surface we wrote down the equations
using F equals MA
we've linearized about our two fixed
points and we find out that one of them
is stable and one of them is unstable
it's a saddle okay so now we're going to
draw the complete full phase portrait of
this problem and see if it makes
physical sense
and this thing actually has eigen
vectors so you can verify this in MATLAB
that this has eigen vectors 1 1 and 1
minus 1 so my saddle is actually rotated
by 45 degrees so it's actually stable
here unstable here ok remember we look
at the eigen values to figure out its
stability then we look at the eigen
vectors to figure out which directions
the stable and the unstable directions
are ok so you can just verify that for
this matrix these are the eigen vectors
and this is what my saddle looks like
it's rotated by 45 degrees ok so now
we're ready to draw the phase portrait
and we're gonna draw position versus
velocity ok we want to know what the
position does with respect to the
velocity and vice versa in time for this
problem so I have 0 0 and I have 1 0
those are my special points that are
fixed points so what do I know is true
in a small neighborhood around 0 0 the
fixed point 0 0 it's a stable center
right ok so I can draw that as I'm gonna
use blue for a neutrally stable I think
that was about right ok so around a
small vicinity of this fixed point I'm
gonna have kind of mutually stable
solutions ok if I start in just check
have our picture here if I start in a
vicinity of this well I'm just gonna
oscillate around that well forever
that's what this is showing me that my
position and velocity are just
oscillating out of phase in circles ok
what about in a small vicinity of this
point 1 0 which corresponds to me being
at the top of this hump with no velocity
it's a saddle it's unstable and it's
rotated by 45 degrees
okay so locally I'm going to have an
unstable direction
and I'm also going to have a stable
direction so green is moving in red is
moving out and I would have been able to
tell which of these was stable and
unstable by looking at the eigenvectors
which eigenvector corresponding to
lambda plus 1 and which eigenvalue
corresponding to lambda minus 1 so which
of these eigenvectors corresponds to
lambda minus 1 the green because it's
stable okay and then we can start
piecing together what happens in the
middle just using our physical intuition
okay so for example if I'm on this point
and I nudged it ever so slightly either
left or give it a negative velocity it's
going to move down to the same potential
height and then it's going to turn
around and come back up and ever so
slowly reach the top again all right
that's one of these solutions that
corresponds to pushing either a little
to the left or a little down we follow
this red curve until we come back to
that fixed point in infinite time this
takes infinite time to go around this
trajectory okay what if I push it a
little harder what if I met this top and
I push it to the left a negative
velocity pretty hard well it's going to
overshoot and then it's going to go over
the hump and down to positive infinity
with positive velocity okay so that
corresponds to here right I have a large
negative velocity at that X position at
this x position I have a large negative
velocity so I'm going to overshoot come
back around and then go to infinity in X
I'm going to go to X infinity with
positive X velocity
and that's gonna accelerate an
accelerating accelerates so we actually
know what's gonna happen basically for
all time the final case here I can just
draw this for you if I start out here
like way out here then I'm just gonna go
to positive infinity okay so this is the
phase portrait for this problem this is
what essentially like this is the
solution of the ODF this is one form of
the solution of the OTE lots of times we
can't write down X of T equals blah blah
blah blah blah right for nonlinear
systems I can't actually write down a
closed form solution for you for lots of
problems but I can draw you the picture
that tells you everything that's gonna
happen in the system for every single
initial condition you can name I can
tell you where that initial condition
will go okay so this is called a phase
portrait because it tells you the phase
between the variables and we obtain this
by finding fixed points and there
linearizations and then for this problem
we just used our reasoning to figure out
how to connect the two okay questions
this is kind of probably new for
something yeah
so your question there there is a reason
why the the arrows are pointing
clockwise and I think I don't know I
might mess this up but I'm pretty sure
that it's the difference between this
and this so if the negative is switched
I think it switches the order of the I
think it switches the order of the
circle but I don't I'm not 100% sure
about that yeah there's a slim chance
you know I could have bombed the error
of the direction of these arrows you
should like double check on your own
okay like it's actually it's worth
really looking at what the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues are and usually I can
tell what direction the center has to go
by looking at the direction of my saddle
because I know that it has to go this
way if my saddle is coming in and coming
out this way okay other questions so
this may seem like we took a simple
system that we actually understood and
we made it really really complicated
that is that is kind of what we just did
but what's nice about this picture is
that this is a geometric way of thinking
that generalizes to much much harder
problems than just a bead on a wire okay
this is exactly how we design spacecraft
trajectories to go to orbit the moons of
Jupiter okay in fact this looks eerily
like the phase portrait for the Sun
Jupiter system except that one has an
extra dimension so there's a direction
coming out of the plane that makes this
a bulb and this is ranked one saddle so
it's got two stable directions in one
unstable direction okay so this picture
allows us to visualize systems and
solutions that we can't write down close
form solutions for okay other questions
I'm gonna like expect you to know how to
draw a face portrait so if you have
questions
you ask them hey we find our fix points
we linearize around those fixed points
to find out what the geometry looks like
and at the very least we could draw a
picture in this vicinity in this
vicinity but sometimes with good
physical intuition we can actually draw
the full global face portrait this is
just from physics so let's say I perturb
a teeny tiny epsilon in this red
direction which corresponds I mean
imagine I had a bead sitting here and I
push it like a thousandth of a
millimeter over and there's no friction
it's gonna take a really long time to
accelerate down and then it's gonna take
a really long time to come back to rest
at the top okay
okay I'm gonna do another example and
then if I have time I'm actually going
to show you what the geometry of this
looks like for the Sun Jupiter problem
because it's awesome if I can find it so
for example on homework three you're
going to draw this phase portrait for
the pendulum system okay you have theta
double dot equals minus sine of theta
you're going to draw the phase portrait
for that system with and without damping
so let's add damping here okay let's say
I add friction to this system simple
enough I wish I didn't erase my board X
double dot equals was at plus or minus X
minus X plus x squared minus X dot we're
gonna add damping now we're not going to
go through and recompute all the
eigenvalues that's a pain in the ass but
let's just guess what the solution is
because we know physics okay
this point was a center and this point
was a saddle what do you think happens
to the center when I add damping
it becomes a stable sink a stable spiral
right so if I start here now I all eight
but I don't get to quite the same height
then I oscillate again and I oscillate
again until I eventually have no energy
and I rest in that well so it's a stable
spiral sink okay this is one of the
cases we wrote up on the board in the
first part of the class the saddle is
much more robust to small changes in the
linearization it's still a saddle this
saddle is going to stay the same so now
what I have this is kind of a fun
picture to draw see if I can do it
so now the origin is a stable spiral and
I still have my saddle point out here is
that right yep except now this
trajectory gets instead of coming around
and coming back to rest at the fixed
points it gets trapped in the well so if
I take this point and I nudged it a
teeny teeny little bit to the left now
now it's going to oscillate but it's not
going to get quite as high because there
was friction and now it's not going to
get quite as high and it's going to come
to rest in that stable fixed point which
is exactly what this picture is showing
but I'm coming to rest in this fixed
point then some other trajectory has
just enough energy to come to rest at
the top and then everything else just
goes to infinity like we expected so the
only difference here is that this Center
instead of having closed circular orbits
it now becomes a spiral sync so when I
add damping my center here became a
spiral sync you could have figured this
out by looking at the eigenvalues of the
linearization you would have found that
these eigenvalues are now stable or you
could just think about it physically
like if I add damping this well becomes
on a tractor it stabilizes questions
should make some physical sense right
like this picture now this idea of a
spiral sink should really kind of make
sense it's this well with friction okay
for the last example this one's kind of
neat this is my first favorite vector
field in 2d at least I guess my favorite
vector field in 3d is the three-body
problem okay so this one's really cool
so now we're going to have X double dot
equals minus X cubed plus X and then
we'll have this optional damping okay
and this corresponds to a particle in
this potential field where we have a
double potential well it's not a lot
more complicated right this is if I
integrate this I get an X to the fourth
over four minus an x squared over two
and that's exactly what this potential
well is and again the bead you know it's
going to stay in this well if it starts
with low enough energy it's gonna stay
in this well if it starts with low
enough energy if it starts up here if
you kick it to the right it's going to
go around and around yeah we know what
this solution is going to do so we write
this X dot equals call it y y dot equals
X minus X cubed and then again my
damping term is this optional - y
okay so what are the fixed points let's
say forget the damping for now what are
the fixed points of this system
okay so why definitely has to equal zero
yeah and X could be 0 or a plus or minus
1 okay so this is minus 1 plus 1 and 0
these are where my partial derivative of
U with respect to x equals 0 ok so I can
compute the Jacobian of this or my
linearization so d FD vector X is equal
to 0 1 and then 1 minus 3x squared 0 if
I had damping there would be a minus 1
here right because there would be a
minus y here so maybe I'll do that in
blue so there could be a minus y here
for optional damping and then I would
get a minus 1 here and it would make my
eigen values stable in the wells okay
now you can kind of in MATLAB now you
can just plug in these fixed points into
this equation and you can get the eigen
values and eigen vectors and what we're
going to find is that our fixed points
are you know 0 0 1 0 and minus 1 0 and
when I plug these in and compute the
eigen values and eigen vectors I find
that the zero zero point is a saddle and
that both of these points are centers
they have kind of plus or minus I I gave
values and this is kind of like plus or
minus 1 it makes sense this point is a
saddle and these points are centers like
we should just be able to write down the
phase portrait for this I don't even
need to do the linearization or the
fixed points I know exactly what the
system is going to do so let's just do
that so now in the X Y variables so Y is
my velocity here we have three fixed
points we have a 1 at minus 1 0 and plus
1
okay I know that both of these wells
with no damping our centers okay so I
can have circles here I think they're
going this way can't guarantee it let's
go with it okay and then I have a saddle
point here with an unstable direction
and again I would find out what
direction this is by looking at the
eigenvectors of the linearization at
that points in a stable direction and
the orbit that couples these two is very
very similar to before okay so if I
start in this well I stay in this well I
just oscillate back and forth if I start
in this well I stay in this well I also
like back and forth if I kick this
saddle a teeny bit to the right I go
around to the right and then I come back
and the same thing for the left but if I
give a little more energy let's say I
start it with a pretty big kick in this
direction then I'm going to move up
higher than I was before come back
around and then go up higher than before
and come back around and I'm going to so
that's this exposition but with a little
more velocity I go around and around and
around forever I just keep going around
and around and around forever I go up
and then back and then up and then back
forever and ever and ever
so that's the phase portrait for this
system I mean you should be able to do
this for the pendulum now right we have
saddles and centers we know exactly what
it's going to do yeah
every line has to have an arrow the
arrow tells me which direction time is
going time goes forward this direction
goes this way in time and it really is
this way instead of the other way
because if I think about it if I start
with a positive velocity at this
position that's a positive velocity then
my X moves in the positive direction so
it has to go this way if I start with a
negative velocity if I push it this way
so now it's coming back around and it's
got a negative velocity negative
velocity at that point my X is moving in
the negative direction so this arrow
really has to point this way okay
there's all these little tricks to check
which way your arrows are pointing
correctly okay I will let you figure out
what this looks like if I add damping
it's awesome these break into spirals I
have a t-shirt that I made that has this
vector filled with spiral sinks and I'll
show you some time but I want to show
you this in P plane a MATLAB function
because this is really really useful and
I have two minutes left so I'll do it
quickly perfect okay you can go to
Google you can type in P plane and then
you can download this function from a
website at Rice it's called P plane it's
awesome you hit f5 and we're gonna run
it and then I type in my vector field so
my vector field is X dot equals y y dot
equals X minus X cubed and I am going to
add friction minus y and I'm gonna plot
from like - five - five - four - four
something like that you click proceed
and it will draw all of these these
arrows and I can click anywhere in the
screen I want and it'll draw the phase
portrait for me it's awesome
I'm just gonna keep clicking this is a
lot of fun and so you see that I have a
saddle point in the middle and it's kind
of mediating where trajectories which
well the trajectories get trapped in
some of them get trapped in this left
well some of them get trapped in this
right well and everything from infinity
is getting sucked into one of these two
wells right because every trajectory on
that curve will eventually get damped
out to be living one of those two wells
so you can use P plane on the homework
this is fine this is a great tool you
could write your own P plane using OD 45
it's not that hard this is a pretty
slick program though okay that's
everything today thank you
you